Speaker 1: OK, let's follow up about a couple
of stories from last week, as many of you
know, if you watched last week radical Republican
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Green equated
wearing a mask on the floor of the House of
Representatives to how Jews were killed during
the Nazi Holocaust of World War Two.
This was a completely outrageous comment and
not even that many Republicans criticized
her for it, most of them staying silent.
But now she's just denying that she ever said
it.
She was on the Dr. Gina prime time program
on Real America's Voice network.
I have no idea what that is either.
And she said, you know, really, I wasn't comparing
anything to the Holocaust and it wasn't about
masks or something.
I don't even understand.
Let's take a look at it together and see if
we can figure it out.
Speaker 6: I'm going to continue to fight
back against Speaker Maskell.
That's what I call Speaker Pelosi, Speaker
Maskell and her ridiculous, tyrannical mass
policies.
But the biggest outrage is people being treated
like second class citizens simply because
they refuse to to show a passport, a passport,
a vaccine passport.
And I had compared it to to the way that the
horrible way that Jewish people had been treated
by having to show their papers of who they
are.
Well, without a phone call or a text message,
all of a sudden I find out on the news that
Kevin McCarthy, Elise Stefanik and unfortunately,
Steve Scalise had all condemned my remarks.
And in their own own condemnation of my remarks,
they didn't even have it right.
What I had said in the first place, they were
just misstating things I had said.
And then also they were just preaching to
the media mobs talking points.
So this is this is a problem.
They didn't have to attack me.
Nancy Pelosi doesn't attack her own.
And I think the GOP needs to do better.
So what was the message you were trying to
convey their.
Well, the message is this we don't need to
have Americans treated like second class citizens
simply because they don't want to get the
vaccine, the vaccine is not even FDA certified
yet.
It hasn't been approved by the FDA.
But yet we have schools like the University
of Virginia telling their students that they
can't return to in-person classes without
getting the vaccine.
Well, that's a violation of their freedoms,
their rights and their hipple rights.
Schools and universities should not step in,
especially when there's side effects being
shown with these vaccines.
And it's not FDA approved and people have
the right to choose, especially young people
that are in the lowest risk group and don't
need the vaccine anyways.
Most of them do not.
Freedom is so precious, we have to protect
it.
But we can't allow the Democrats and those
in charge that think they know better than
us and think they can control everything that
we try to do in our daily lives.
We can't allow them to force us into socialism
and having a tyrannical government, we have
to stand up against these aggressions and
it's important that we speak out and do that.
And so you do reject the media narrative or
accusation, I guess, that says you compared
wearing a mask to the Holocaust.
You say that's that's untrue.
That's not at all what you meant by that.
Oh, it's completely untrue.
Anyone can ask David Brody.
He was he was interviewing me at the time
when I made those statements and I wasn't
even talking about mass persay.
It was it was talking about the mistreatment
of being treated like a second class citizen.
And I never said the word Holocaust.
It's just the same as I never said the words
Jewish space lasers.
But then the media made that one up, too.
Speaker 1: She is just so gross.
I mean, just really a disgusting person.
Now, of course, she did say it.
Here are her original comments.
Let's take a look.
And you're going to notice if you're of normal
English proficiency, it's really clear what
she's saying.
It's really clear what she meant.
Speaker 6: This woman is mentally ill.
You know, we can look back at a time in history
where people were told to wear a gold star
and they were definitely treated like second
class citizens, so much so that they were
put in chains and taken to gas chambers in
Nazi Germany.
And this is exactly the type of abuse that
Nancy Pelosi is talking about.
Speaker 1: So she's claiming, I guess, that
because in that segment we just watched, she
didn't use the word Holocaust, that the entire
comment really was not equating mask wearing
to what was done to the Jews during the Holocaust.
But, Marjorie, when you talk about trains
taking Jews to gas chambers in Nazi Germany,
that's the Holocaust that that was during
World War two.
It's just what it is.
Using the word Holocaust or not doesn't really
make it any different.
And it's also extra wacky that just a few
days ago she was defending this.
She was doubling down.
She was saying, yeah, I said it.
And then now she said, that's not actually
what I said.
It's certainly not what I meant, whether she
knows this or not.
This is a technique called the fire hose of
falsehood.
Now, it's not to be confused with gaslighting.
It's related to gaslighting.
But it's not exactly gaslighting not to be
confused with the Gish Gallop.
It's related to the Gish Gallop.
But Gish Gallop is, when you say a bunch of
different things during a debate, particularly
when there's limited time and it makes it
difficult to refute you.
The fire hose of falsehood is where you just
claim different things at different opportunities.
Trump did this all the time.
He would take every position on an issue over
a period of a few days.
The issue is China, Trump would say one thing
about China during a debate and then he would
say something different about China on Fox
News the next day, and then he would tweet
something different about China on day three.
And number one, it makes it difficult for
us to suss out what is this person's actual
position, what are they actually claiming.
And it also makes people sort of give up on
trying to figure out what the truth is, because
it just seems also complicated.
And then lastly, it's also a technique that
increases the likelihood that anybody can
find one of your positions that you like.
Trump would do this, for example, on I think
this was on abortion.
Remember, one on abortion.
He I'm thinking back to 2016.
He was asked, should the woman I'm against
abortion, OK?
Should the woman be punished if she gets an
abortion?
And he said, well, yes, she should.
And then a lot of pro lifers love that.
And then the next day he said, yeah, actually,
that's not really what I meant.
And so, like, no matter what your position
is, you could find an instance of Trump saying
something that you probably liked and just
say less than he did say that one thing there.
So I think I agree with him on this issue.
And this is the sort of this is how you weaponize
this information.
And if you remember that quote from Trump
about you can't believe what you're seeing,
the exact quote was, stick with us.
Don't believe the crap you see from these
people.
The fake news, what you're seeing and what
you're reading is not what's happening.
That is the sort of full conclusion of the
weaponization of disinformation, telling people
even your own senses betray you.
Just listen to me.
Well, what if you're saying something different
every two days?
Just listen to me.
It's a smart strategy when your voters are
so clueless, do and say horrible things and
then pretend they never happened because it
muddies up the message.
And that's what Margery Taylor Green is doing.
They get the info out to the people they are
targeting, but then they do their best to
walk it back and end up suffering no repercussions.
Think of it like posting retractions in a
newspaper that almost nobody notices after
your lead story has already had the impact
you wanted to have.
That's what they're doing.
That's what Margery Taylor Green either.
I'm not even saying she's doing it out of
a calculation, but it does work when your
constituents are Marjorie Taylor Green's constituents.